as the early mist lifts so the first
skiers arrive
and these slopes are about to get a
little busier
travel restrictions to france have been
lifted and the british are coming that
is a huge relief for those who rely on
british visitors to keep them going
people like shona who runs a ski school
here
we've got this far and i think if it
hadn't been lifted you know now or in
the next couple of weeks there would be
a lot of fallout
we can't survive with no cash turnover
you know businesses can't survive
without turnover um so we're not paying
ourselves actually at the moment we're
just trying to bring money in from the
business for the business you know so we
we have to get to a certain level before
we can start to do that
now that sense of gloom is lifting the
outlook is brighter
here in chamonix one in four tourists is
normally british the only country that
sends more holiday makers to the french
alps
is france itself well this isn't just
about frustrated british winter sports
fans breathing a sigh of relief it's
also the story of a economic rescue plan
because there are plenty of resorts and
businesses up here in the french alps
that are dependent on holiday makers
from the uk
some questions do remain it's not clear
whether children will need covered
passports and unvaccinated travelers
really aren't welcome in france but
things are clearly moving in the right
direction
giles rents out a chalet in the town
this is like something out of a fairy
tale most of his visitors are british so
the decision to readmit tourists was
crucial well it's completely saved our
season
we're going to be fully booked now for
february march and april so with those
those three months we can we can survive
and have an okay season
and we were lucky in that we managed to
get a few bookings over christmas new
year to to fill in some of the
cancellations
winter sport holidays are designed to be
a blend of thrills and relaxation
but business here has recently been all
stress and not much fun now the way
ahead looks a lot more inviting adam
parsons sky news chamonix